le paysage près du lac metab escaig à
abu faire rêver il rappelle un épisode
cauchemardesque à rené ottawa le show le
postulat le présumé abuseurs d'enfants
raymond bédard qui enseigne à l'école
deux jours de manouane l'a fait monter
dans une chaloupe en lui proposant
d'aller dîner à son chalet il n'avait
que 10 ans après le dîner il aussi le
cas commencent ils à sortir son pénis
puis guy ni coups et lui dit avoir été
victimes à répétition de roger garceau
un autre ex enseignant de l'école deux
jours de manouane lui aussi décédé
aujourd'hui les deux hommes auraient
sévi dans les années 60 et 70
on ne subit pas évident parler de soi
aujourd'hui on ne subit pas les mains
une atrocités inimaginables de cet
individu là nous a carrément volé notre
notre enfance j'ai agressé sexuellement
je veux qu'elles veulent québec sache
qu'elle soit d'un monstre qu'on envoie
ici à man moi lise dubé accompagne les
vingt-deux victimes des deux présumés
agresseurs à titre d'intervenant au
centre de santé de manouane il ya eu
beaucoup d'attachement
il ya eu aussi de torture il a eu aussi
de séquestration castration là là
vraiment violent et défis et
le garçon les jeunes enfants que lui
pouvait ramasser comme cela dans des
loges pendant qu'ils jouaient puis les
amener chez lui prendre leur bain le
disais je de l'avis de tous salle elle
est l'instigatrice du recours civil
contre le gouvernement du canada qui
selon la requête n'aurait jamais dû
embaucher rhji garceau lorsqu'on
commande son dossier du ministère de
l'éducation on constate que si le
fédéral avait pris la peine de vérifier
ses antécédents et l'aurait vu que la
vie déjà perdu son brevet a déjà plaidé
coupable au criminel pour des
attouchements sur des enfants qu'il
enseignait et malgré ça il a réussi à se
faire engager le ministère des relations
couronne autochtone et des affaires du
nord canada a refusé de réagir aux
allégations touchant l'école deux jours
de manouane puisque la cause est devant
les tribunaux
les victimes ne crois pas que les cas de
manouane est unique
leur avocat soupçonne d ébut à travers
le réseau des 700 écoles gérées par le
gouvernement fédéral je sais qu'ils ont
en règle et en grand nombre dans nord
québécois
ils savent qu'ils avaient des abuseurs
dans leurs écoles de jour pour certains
d'entre eux les traumatismes ne faisait
que commencer et ont vécu l'enfer dans
cette école là et puis là on les envoie
à l'extérieur ils sont contents sont
contents 10 enfin je vais pouvoir
quitter cette école pour aller dans une
autre école mais arrive là bas personne
assez les mêmes abus qui arrive en or
l'enfant comment comment vous pensez que
un enfant puisque l'on tire
comment
comment il arrive à faire des projets
derrière non plus tout est brisé
même maintenant même lincoln elle
intéresse plus il a tout et moi qui vais
l'éducation pourtant pas là c'est de la
bullshit
malgré tout guy nico et a réussi à s'en
sortir notamment grâce à cette passion
pour le sport et l'enseignement de
l'éducation physique comme un toit
il est d'abord devenu enseignant et le
voilà maintenant directeur de l'école
primaire la même école où travaillaient
les deux abuseurs présumé et c'est mort
de mon temps beau radio canada madd
roanne